même les dictionnaires veulent faire du
buzz c'est incroyable non mais
franchement c'est du buzz parce que
maintenant on a tout sur internet donc
il a acheté un dico personne donc ils se
disent bon bah on va rajouter des mots
tu as tellement ridicule on a assez de
je pense que c'est assez la fin du monde
comme ça pour qu'on des mots comme ça
dans les académiciens que j'ai écouté
parler non que j'ai écouté parler et qui
disent que si justement on veut qu'une
langue reste vivante ne meurt pas comme
le latin et d'autres langues il faut
absolument qu'elle continue d'évoluer et
qu'on la joue systématiquement
parler bah tout fragile il y aura un
contexte ça veut dire que j'essaye de te
marcher dessus ça veut dire que j'essaye
de t'éteindre je veux dire vas-y
lâche-moi tu es un babtou fragile ouais
c'est comme c'est comme une espèce de
c'est comme si tu veux faire tu veux
humilier le mec ou tu veux le rabaisser
et pourquoi ça ce mot-là il sera
d'accord
c'est quoi une grande bien sûr c'est ma
meuf c'est ma femme exactement
à chaque fois que j'ai entendu des mecs
dire babtou fragile c'était pas positif